les dirigeants du TMB sortent les gros
moyens avant la trêve des confiseurs
après une onzième défaite en 15 matchs
le coach du Tour métropole basket vient
d'être remercié remplacé par une
pointure Valérie Garnier l'ancienne
sélectionneuse des Bleus a pour mission
de stopper l'hémorragie du club qui est
avant dernier du championnat de National
une Faustine Luneau
à peine annoncé déjà arrivé ce matin
Valérie Garnier animé son premier
entraînement en tant que nouvelle coach
du TMB pour l'ancienne sélectionneuse de
l'équipe de France féminine il
s'agissait de prendre ses marques et
surtout de faire connaissance avec ses
joueurs je vais les découvrir petit à
petit mais j'ai déjà scouté trois quatre
matchs de Tours donc je sais qui est qui
est quelles sont les forces de chacun
même si en entretient individuel il me
parleront un peu plus un peu plus d'eux
je vais découvrir la nationale et je
vais découvrir le milieu masculin mais
mais je suis prête car celle qui n'avait
jusque là entraîné que des équipes
féminines souhaitaient se tourner vers
le basket masculin le club a saisi
l'opportunité en lui proposant un
premier contrat d'un an et demi qu'elle
a accepté je me suis dit pourquoi pas
parce que je sais que tour c'est une
ville de basket je sais que tout est un
club structuré et ambitieux et puis
j'avais vu les garçons jouer et je pense
que c'est des bons mecs et
ils m'ont confirmé dès ce matin que des
travailleurs et qu'ils avaient pas peur
de l'engagement et de l'engagement il va
leur en falloir l'équipe traverse
actuellement une mauvaise période avec
11 défaites en 15 matchs elle est avant
dernière de sa poule en championnat
alors en s'offrant une telle pointure du
basket le club espère sauver sa saison
on est fier d'avoir un profil comme
Valérie avec son expérience et son
palmarès ça renommée on a le téléphone
qui sonne pour nous dire c'est c'est
super et impressionnant maintenant nous
on veut surtout que les victoires soient
là et voilà c'est c'est bien d'avoir
Valérie et mais Valérie des victoires ce
sera encore mieux premier essai demain
pour la nouvelle coacher son équipe le
TMB affront travers pour sa 16e journée
en première phase du championnat